- Who wants donuts?
- It's only itself and that number.
- What number comes before?
- There are some pernicious effects
that come from the fact
that we are such social creatures,
and one of them leads to the role
that identity plays in learning.
As human beings,
we are very aware of how we are the same
or different than others.
We're conscious of how we look different,
how we act different,
how we speak with different languages.
Each of those gives us a kind
of identity about ourselves.
It turns out that the studies
have demonstrated that
your identity as a learner
plays a huge role in the pathway
that you take in school,
the kinds of classes you
think you'd be attracted to,
the disciplines or the careers
you think you'd be good at as
opposed to poor at.
- You attach this.
Can you attach this?
(machine whirs)
- Tell me some ideas,
what else could that graph be telling me?
- By second grade, girls have absorbed
the stereotype as to whether or not
their academic interests would tend
towards math or not.
In the United States,
girls by second grade
will report, girls aren't
interested in math.
Girls aren't good at math
and they don't care about math.
By third grade, they've absorbed that
with regard to themselves.
They say, "I'm not interested in math.
"I don't care about math.
"I'm not good at math."
That's independent of what their
scores are in math.
This work is demonstrating how important
the belief system is to academic skills.
It doesn't matter where
in the world you live,
you want to belong.
You don't want to be alone.
Teachers who have a tendency
to work on the math skill itself
can ignore this other part,
the psychology of your belief system.
It's so important for teachers
and parents to understand the power
of the social brain.
If we're helping our children
negotiate their place in the world,
we have to understand the degree
to which their social responses
to others and from others
are building identities that will
allow them or cut them off
from pathways that they might follow.